and on that note we have take off the
game has just started choco bars
starting off with the ready with Knight
f3 so this makes me a little bit worried
that she's not going for the pawn pushes
right away but this might be part of the
theory that she learned yeah so I mean
she's obviously good height of 23 um
this is this this is actually exactly
what I showed her so this is this as if
it's part of preparation then then that
makes sense right so so basically what I
showed her was I showed her basically
try to get the King out of Center I mean
I'll tell you exactly what I showed her
after 4 since next move which is that
when black puts the two pawns in the
center you push the pawn to d3 to stop
black from going 8-4 here and then next
move you castle of King so so far I know
that uh the chalk bar is in preparation
as far as force and goes I don't think
he normally plays the setup per se so I
I'm actually I don't think I've ever
seen him out to face its opening so it's
gonna be interesting to see what force
and comes up with here in terms of his
next couple of moves right and and one
thing about the setup that you taught
chocolate bars is it's less common
usually people who are starting off play
efore or d4 so do you think that her
opponent having less familiarity with
that line gives her any advantage I
think certainly this is a very good
start considering that force and it's
definitely the high higher rate of
player getting getting out of something
that he's comfortable with at the very
start of the game certainly should uh
should be to her benefit obviously I
expect well I don't know I wonder what
horse won't do here I feel like he
should probably develop to bhishma
castle the king but at the same time he
likes to play games he likes to do stuff
that has like a straightforward plan and
I don't see a straightforward plan here
for black really other than developing
castling so I could see this um I could
see this being a relatively slow game
here and in terms of what you taught
choco bars it's really fun to see see
you predict what she's gonna do what was
the next plan after she castles her King
I think the next plan is to play Knight
c3 e for those are probably the next two
moves or to play Oh foursome plays Ethan
you you called his style very well he
likes those aggressive moves here
although in this line choco bars is
going to be able to exchange
Queens and either make forsen retreat
his night and lose some time developing
or take with his King and not be able to
castle which usually feels pretty
uncomfortable first oh my god she
blended right into oh my gosh she just
trades the Queen's here yep oh my gosh
she's gonna be down upon at the start oh
no oh no no no no no Knight g5 and
Knight c3 and White's up upon ya so I
very very bad start for for perforce and
he's still very much in the game she's
only gonna be down one pawn but this is
and she thought she played it so quickly
how long has chocolate bars been playing
chess for this is really impressive I'm
probably like a week or so the only
problems I literally showed her this
position so that's that's why it's not
oh you showed her this particular Queen
trait and an idea back tonight alright
you're you're you're a wizard this is
the second time he predicted a game yeah
so I mean here what she should do is you
should take the pawn with the knight
Knight takes and Bishop takes and
White's up one pawn but it's it's a very
balanced position still a lot of pieces
on the board lock going on so that the
game is definitely not over at all not
by any stretch of the imagination right
so she is gonna be up a pawn she's gonna
have the white pieces she still do
lower-rated player among the two and on
top of that she has two minutes up so if
you had to give sign some kind of
prediction or odds for this game given
the current situation what would it be
um I would say it's still probably as I
said starting him I think it's probably
8020 I think forsen probably is about
80% favorite and I would say chalk bars
is maybe 20% I would say it's so roughly
the same even though she's up one pawn
although actually the fact that they're
not Queens on the board certainly
diminishes the ideas of attacking with
your with your pieces because generally
you want Queens and rooks to attack the
opponent's king and here we're already
in an endgame so I think that actually
diminishes the odds of a of a force and
like a real attack I still think the
game is very unclear but without Queens
it's gonna be it's gonna be harder for
them to to find tactics fair enough and
now
the next two moves or so are pretty
straightforward for both sides they have
some pieces that are not developed the
minor pieces for forcing the bishop four
chocolate bars as well as getting the
rooks into play is this an opening or I
I know we're in the endgame but these
are opening principles still that you
expect them to see um yeah I mean I
think I think again when I try to help
out any of any of these streamers it's
about trying to follow plan develop the
pieces get the King out of the center I
try to do something that I think they
can think remember something that's
relatively simple it's not like it's not
a hard or difficult plan to see um so so
yeah I think I think so far chocolate
Bart's is doing very well
forsen I mean this this was always my
sort of the one thing I've noticed and
for since games that has been a big
weakness is that he likes to play very
aggressively at the start but then but
then he's sort of if he doesn't get the
big attack he kind of loses a steam very
quickly in terms of trying to find the
right ideas so um that's the one thing I
would say that is maybe that my one
critique of force and said he doesn't he
doesn't really if he doesn't get the
right attack he doesn't get the steam
the initiative going right at the start
of the game sometimes it's hard for him
to to find find the plans that's fair
and what about choco bar style from what
you've seen so far um I mean I think
consideration is relatively new to the
game I think it's pretty straightforward
what she should be doing here trying to
take this open file where the rook can
attack the knight on the d8 square so I
mean I think the main thing she needs to
remember is develop this Bishop very
important that she doesn't play b3 here
actually beat her would be a very bad
move because I'm black and go Bishop to
d4 and black will be up on it being up a
piece so that's that's the one thing
that I would say she has to be very
careful not to do is just to find
another way to develop okay rook e1 is
reasonable but so yeah it's gonna be
interesting I think I think all three
results are very much in the up here up
in the air here and I wouldn't be
shocked to this might actually end up
being a draw I'm gonna make a small
small yeah there's like a 10 percent
chance of a draw here well now she has
to be careful about the tactic because
forsen is sir I need to remove her
Knight and then oh and now she just
blended a bishop Oh oops oops oops yeah
that was an unfortunate news I'd say
temper side yeah oh man she was waiting
for you to finish the prediction but hey
I mean she did yeah remember your advice
from the opening its its post about
blunder pieces when you've been playing
for a week like she has yeah I mean I
think the other thing also is the reason
that she played this pawn push to a3 is
is because there was a line that I
showed her with the knight on f3 and
Bishop g4 where you play h3 so I think
she automatically saw the pin and she
was thinking about the knight on the
other side where you go Bishop g4 yeah
so she mixed up one of the ideas there
and something that you know players
always start improving it's just
differentiating between plans with
positions and small differences with
them and now she's pushing f3 so you
know maybe she'll activate her king but
what she would really need to do if she
wants to have chances is try to develop
that Bishop as quickly as possible
and bring the other rook to the open
file here she is down a piece so now the
chances are even more difficult have you
seen your forsen falling victim to some
blunders as well do you think there's a
chance she might trick him who works
before as a nasty that's thought that's
a that's a quality move from force and
playing work to c4 yeah he could he
could he could fall for it I mean I
think the best chance of some kind of
pact rank checkmate or as Felix would
call it the potentate ice skater I think
everyone's heard that term by now so so
yeah I guess we're gonna listen in
though yep so we're we're gonna be
seeing what choco bar has to say
attacking me like a big bully and how do
I defend this pawn she's she's seeing
the direct threats and reacting to them
so that's great mm-hmm yeah I mean so
far it's a tough position she's down one
Bishop for one pawn and she does are the
two pawns that are under attack but I
still think it's well it's bad it's not
it's not beyond the pasta the point
where for something so blundered because
I have seen him actually blunder Queens
find it for free but he's been ahead by
like a lot of material so it's not
completely gone I think at this point
and I could relate with swords and on
that one so definitely could happen to
everyone here she doesn't seem
distraught
first yeah I mean I I think so far it's
it's it's pretty good in terms of
position pushing the pawn to e4 is the
best move but it is kind of a hard move
to find if you're new to the game
because it's sort of like it weakens it
weakens the pawns around your King
potentially so it's a tough move to play
here
she found it yeah she was she was
calculating it out so so yeah so now I
mean force it has to move the bishop he
needs not to make a better not make a
blunder here this is this it feels like
every every move kind of unlike
professional chess there is always a
decent possibility of either player
making a rather serious blunder so it's
you're always kind of on the edge of
your seat I think in a different way so
question for you if forsen plays g6 and
she pushes f4 which is obviously not a
right move because efore is hanging but
do you think it's risky that he might
fall for f5 or that's a tactic he would
see right away um I think f4 is actually
a great bluffing kind of mood because
the forcing doesn't see f5 it doesn't
see that on hanging and allows f4 f5 he
could end up in a lot of trouble oh did
she play it no no I was just explaining
ok sorry I'll stick to arrows for now to
not be confusing but I do think it's a
reasonably good good like Bluff blunder
because if forsen doesn't see it the
game will become very complicated again
and so when you're down a piece I mean
at some point you do have to go for some
Bluff blunders otherwise you're likely
just gonna lose right exactly yeah yeah
and do you have um forsen stream up as
well because maybe we can take it a look
at and see what he's thinking as well of
course
yes the other thing I would say is the
time really matters here yeah I'm only
laughing because of how she was excited
not tear loose a piece I'm good
he does have the right plan he's trying
not to lose his beasts but it might get
stuck on g3 if she sees something like
King G G for king of taking g3 right
yeah I really don't like push page 3
here well now we can move this though
she got those and we're chat we're just
listening in on him trying not to speak
over him I like that she grabbed the
open file I wonder what his responses
yeah this is very tricky also the other
thing that makes us I think very tricky
is the time situations because the fact
that forsen is already down two minutes
on the clock makes us very very dicey
yeah and he's playing 95 now so you've
been right about his style he goes for a
very very aggressive play I guess there
is a chance that at some point he
forgets about the back rank checkmate so
it's still tricky because he's gonna
have to play faster and faster yeah I
tend to agree I mean I think every move
here is critical for both sides every
single move really matters here so what
do you think is the trickiest plan for
white I mean I think the thing is trying
to bring the two guards on and then
double the rooks on the D file log is
would be the best do it's hard to see
but 95 is kind of an obvious move it's
clearly moving the night toward towards
a weird weird spot and you want to take
the take the pond Oh No let's see what
he says after Rick f1o you see it oh he
surely sees it right well he's taking
his time
he is hovering over his rook on c4 what
I'm just gonna stream snipe until he
this situation now he's hovering over
I'm like I'm watching it - what what he
doesn't know what to do I don't know do
you don't know what dude okay we have is
we have a stream pulled up by the way
joke of twitch oh this is so intense I
love watching oh come on dude come on
but he's also using way too much time oh
no you see sexy car oh oh he took it
back he took you back oh now that's
funny
what is he doing today come on oh my god
no come on dude he's getting og 6 played
I'm just gonna wait to see what she does
well he's waiting for his opponent yeah
I thought that that was totally missing
lethal and let me check if we're still
on him
or if we're swapping off okay so he's
muted again on the stream and she just
played rook F to you so she saw the
threat that was good she fixed her
mistake that's very very important yeah
this is I mean this is very very like I
feel like you're physically in pain I
mean it's not that I'm in pain but it's
like I I have very high expectations for
her force and I'm not gonna live like I
do think he is one of the favorites um
but this is kind of one of these moments
in the game where it feels like he kind
of forgot he is one of those slip-ups
luckily it wasn't hanging a rook or a
queen but he had one of these moments
where he completely just like his brain
stopped working and so I'm I like f5
though f5 is a good move to attack the
pawn in the center do you think his time
situation is going to end up causing him
trouble here to fifty five versus five
money yeah I mean I think it really the
next couple moves matter if chaga bars
can avoid blundering like Bishop or
broken the next like three to four moves
I think the time factor will play a very
big role yeah and in terms of what she
should go for now I mean she has a
couple options but what do you think is
the most intuitive good move for her um
intuitive good move I mean I assume
white will probably take the pawn bishop
c1 is is probably the best move but it's
not very intuitive very hard to see it's
moving a bishop backwards the only
person I've seen who has actually been
good at moving knights and bishops
backwards is is neat he'll he's the only
price I've seen who has demonstrated
that ability out of the people that I've
worked with so III definitely earn I
didn't work them but that I've seen the
game's up so I think I I think I mean I
think pawn takes pawn move and by the
way since chad is going insane I am
making a joke for Stannis one of the
best players here so he's definitely
he's no joke yeah and that's why you
have high hopes for him I think it's
actually quite a compliment
to be disappointed when he misses
something like that because you think
it's in his ability so yeah I definitely
I mean I I think he's one of the
strongest players okay now she makes a
bad move and I think forsen is a little
bit too much time here he should see he
should he should see some some good
moves pawn takes pawn or Knight takes
pawn and he should win this game pretty
cleanly here yeah and he's hovering over
the night so it looks like he is going
to see that move but he card you know
you did say if she doesn't blunder a
rook or a bishop so she's down another
pawn but there's still some hope here
yeah I mean I think I think she needs to
bring the King to the center of the
board specifically that's the only
chance she has because I think at this
point that material is so simplified
that forsen is gonna be able to trade
some rocks here and he's he will have a
good good chance of probably king - e3
is the best move but it's again not very
intuitive I don't really see intuitive
moves here for white you can't really
move the rook down to DX there's the
brook you can't move ECD some bishop
that captures it
I'm gonna guess so that she's gonna play
rook d7 here that's that's my prediction
I think she's gonna play with d7o seize
the rook or not I don't know but I think
rook d7 is probably the most logical
move for someone who's nude
she saw King III hikaru yeah so I mean
that certainly improves the situation
yes it's still quite quite bad of course
but I think the thing is with the piece
setup it's still like you can't really
attack the King easily except if you
retreat the night and I don't know but
somehow force and retreating the knight
doesn't feel very it just doesn't feel
very intuitive based on the style that
I've seen from him so so we'll see but
he's gotta move quick or - like he's
getting the time is starting to tick now
the time is starting to actually be a
factor um but that's why I'm so
impressed with King III because like her
pieces are so awkward here her pawns her
rooks are Bishop there's not a lot of
good Square so for her to understand
that she can move her King there when
you're used to being worried about your
King safety I find so impressive this
he's got to be very careful the time is
actually starting to become an issue I
think if he doesn't move in the next 20
seconds this is gonna time is gonna play
a role in this game like all right
Oh oh this is oh my god okay he made a
mission okay and it's a good move as
well so right and now now it's gonna be
even more difficult for her because she
probably senses that her heroics are in
trouble here but I mean she can try
something like h3 which is somewhat
intuitive actually because she played a3
so she might see it mm-hmm right I think
it's it's a it's a reasonable move but I
think certainly um yeah if she can make
a decent move here this is gonna be very
interesting to watch as we as both
players get down to the last like minute
minute half on the clock
oh and I see her drawing arrows she did
she does see okay she didn't draw an
arrow for the threat that the bishop has
but she did throw throw some arrows for
where the knight moves and she does have
h3 on the board so she's actually
considering it here mm-hmm yeah this is
okay she is what three minutes yeah okay
for first okay oh yeah yeah now for
since forsen sees that he can move the
knight right away
so now she has we basically tried to
choose him on the clock like rook d5 is
the only good move here
I think forsen has enough time that he
should be she's gonna see rook d5
because she has to move her rooks from
this pin and oh okay you know I was
wrong yeah I mean I I think at this
point though it's not so much about the
moves it's about whether forsen can play
the moves quickly or not because already
the position is so bad that the time is
really the only way that I think
chocolate bars can win this game yeah
that's fair and she's she's about to
lose another one here so thinking though
he's still thinking like okay I mean as
long as he keeps it above one minute as
long as he keeps his time above one
minute I think he will be in no danger
of losing but it's a time ever gots blow
a minute I think there is there could be
some it could be dangerous it would be
exciting to watch though so I will say
that Chet even if it does happen will
we'll be here enjoying the show so rook
takes c3 she might play Bishop e2 of
course the problem with that is rook
takes c2 check and she has to trade off
more so she should try and keep her
pieces on for as long as possible to
just keep
complicated and try to cheese him on the
grubs now King III of course very
important that she goes up the board
here not back because she if she if she
goes back I think she it's just game
over so you have to bring the King up oh
yeah I now force and will will win the
game I think on the spot here both night
Chuck's should win the game yeah and he
has he has enough time to finish off
with his attack here and then he could
bring his other rook into the game as
well okay he sees it so yeah so King up
one now III is winning probably he'll
play Knight takes pawn I'm guessing but
ether is is a very clean way it creates
a nice checkmate on f2 yeah let's let's
see if he goes for that and now she's
starting to get a little bit lower on
the clone actually it's his sister in
here sorry mm-hmm and she can try to
play something like Bishop e1 survive
for a little longer but yeah I mean the
problem is I think no matter where you
move the piece pon de to next move is
also winning app on d2 is the much more
intuitive move for for human I think
yeah and no stell mate hopes because you
know she still has enough pieces that it
shouldn't happen he has made in one do
you think he's gonna see it uh I would
say it's 5050 okay he doesn't he took
but he still I mean it's still hey
there's zero totally winning there's
just no way that he doesn't win here
because yeah if he had like ten seconds
or something I could see if the fact
he's got one minute plus unfortunately I
think it's just it's just over but you
still have the never resign attitude
right yeah I mean at this point I
wouldn't resign just cuz he's got one
mil on the clock but again it's it's for
us and I don't think I don't think
there's any way he's gonna he's gonna
make a mistake here that's fair and
given your expectations for the players
how do you think they performed in the
match um I think pretty good I would say
fours and got caught in the opening and
something he wasn't expecting so he got
down down one pawn but otherwise it's
been pretty good and he's simplifying so
he's gonna trade his new promoted Queen
for a bishop and now he has a torx and
I'm sure he can do a nice mating
technique here yeah I think with with it
with a minute on the clock there's no
doubt especially with three pawns on the
board if white had like one pawn me
there could be some weird style me but
with three three pawns or there's just
no way that wakin white can avoid losing
here right and if he didn't have pawns
if the King would be on a square where
it's not a were thinking why is he
thinking why why do you yeah like he
wants to make you nervous he's putting
on a show he guard okay yeah now it's
like this is a position that would have
been stalemate if we didn't have the
pawns because the King has nowhere to go
yeah true so it's good to see him
putting content you know maybe he's
gonna run his clock all the way down to
five seconds just for the show
no I I there's no way that these guys
would take that risk that would be way
too dangerous I know I know I'm just
teasing he is still she know she's
taking her time here yeah I mean she
just has to push the pawns but it's
unfortunately it's just it's it's too
much yeah I agree with you there so
let's take a look in and listen to what
Janet is thinking about here since she
hasn't moved yet she's trying to move
her King okay she got it oh it's not
check me yet
oh that was fun to see okay yeah we're
still alive or still listening chat does
you just want to make infinite stuff
deal with it and now I can move the rook
over and Chuck me yeah rook to be one to
take away the square and then promoted
to queen or a rook or a rock if he wants
to go for style points absolutely he
probably has Auto Queen okay I may have
lost really hard but I made forsen do a
lot of
that's true that's true okay I think we
can we can get off of her audio now
mm-hmm honestly a really nice attitude
or is it because she knew she was the
underdog and she felt good about the
fact that she made force and really work
for the game mm-hmm yeah I thought I
thought it was a pretty good performance
by both players forces opening wasn't
perfect but in general most of stuff he
did after that with the exception of not
taking the rook was good yeah and I just
pulled up the opening you were talking
about when he pushed efore as you
mentioned he should have tried moving
his dark square bishop and going for the
castle instead he did fall into that
opening trap and on that no let's just
remind people who's up next because we
do have one more game for y'all today
it's going to be box box versus
literally this is gonna be a very fun
matchup because a box box is another one
of the tournament favorites but Little
League has been putting in a ton of
training time so I'm excited to see how
this match is gonna go up on that note
we're gonna take a quick break and we
will be back with interviews and we are
back we are joined together by both
forsen and choco bars so let's start off
forsen congratulations how does that the
game difficulty compared to your
expectations I wasn't too worried
although I didn't know the opening she
used I had never really played against
that so I wasn't very comfortable and I
lost the part because of it in this dorm
so I was a pawn down and I play serious
and then I made a comeback wait you had
to play serious I'm kidding I had to
focus up a bit material
well Chakravarthy Cara was saying that
he went over this opening with you and
it was awesome that you had it
I'm arise so well are you happy to see
it come on the board yes I was I was
like everything is going according to
plan
and it felt really good and then after
which I struggled the most with is the
mid game to end game where I haven't
because like there's so many situations
anyway that's where things go kind of
downhill for me but I was happy in the
beginning and I was good on time I'm
usually yeah key card do you want to
comment a bit on the time situation
because you had some hilarious reactions
yeah I just saw it like there is this
one moment where you use like two
minutes where you could have captured
the rook on and I'm reeling it up on the
board yeah you use like two minutes in
this position you could have put this
takes work I was like oh my god he's
gonna eat my rook and then you did it
[Music]
yeah I mean fortunately it didn't make a
difference but nonetheless you use know
in China that we really started getting
worried that something bad would happen
I was not worried I was excited I wanted
to clock you out faster towards the end
scary and yeah so towards the end for us
and it seemed like you were almost
getting into science some time trouble
were you just trying to be very careful
I wa I was as soon as I was up a piece I
wasn't worried about the time that much
because you can always get it back after
you trade a lot of pieces and there's
like not a lot of things from the board
you can always get the time back by just
doing silly moves so I wasn't too
worried about that but I was worried
when I was down upon and I had to think
of ways to get back my material so I
think it was at four minutes or five
minutes or something but I wasn't like
super worried
fair enough and he Cory were there
moments where you sought after chocolate
bars blender the piece that she could
have been able to get counterplay yeah
problem is middle stage instead of this
rook f1 move is possible to stack the
rooks on the D file just go back like
three right here you can play with d3 or
yes sir
d3 to protect the pawn and double up
your X then you try to check on the back
[Music]
okay yeah I was really worried because I
could see that if he brought his horse
down to f3 he would fork my Rick end of
my King so I was thinking of ways but I
didn't see the d3 noted yeah that makes
a lot of sense and Hikari do you have
any tips for the players maybe when they
get into the middlegame stage and it
becomes a lot more complicated for how
they can improve for future matches well
I thought what forsen did like what
force and it was very impressive I
thought this idea bringing you once you
were up to peace bringing this rook down
to e4 and then c4 was a very good idea
to stop the bishop from ever becoming
active when you moved it over and attack
the two pawns
I thought your play was good maybe just
the time usage wasn't wasn't wasn't
perfect but nonetheless overall I
thought it was a very good game after
that hiccup in the opening so I thought
it's very good and as far as Janna I
mean it's just try to try to be a little
bit more have an idea of what you need
to do in the middle little part of the
game probably and Janet we took we took
a look at your game towards the end
there when your King had no space to go
and it seems like you had some funny
comments I'm gonna pull it up do you
mind relaying those to the chat yeah the
King was stuck in a hard situation and I
realize doesn't really have me and check
me so I thought there is a glitch in the
system but I could just move my stuff
yeah report the bug on chess comm know
exactly well moving forward forsen is
there any opponents that you're most
intimidated about honestly no my baby
better at me than me at chess
but I think a tournament format I'm the
favorite for sure all right a lot of
confidence there and chalk Avars
obviously you have been playing chess
just as of a few weeks now so it's still
a relatively new games what are your
hopes for yourself in the tournament I
think I can take on NIM or slicker I
think forsen is definitely our hardest
opponent in our group so the fact that I
you know I did okay I held my ground for
a good amount of time and I did get that
pond beginning and three I played MIM in
three days I think I have ready to
improve and hopefully get at least one
game yeah absolutely I mean you are the
underdog in this matchup and forsen has
the confidence so maybe force and if you
want to mute muta so that we don't you
know boost your confidence even more
here but it will definitely feel a lot
easier when you get paired with somebody
who also has been playing for a similar
time as you and on that note for Sidhu
you think watching commentary I know
you've been you know sticking to the Lin
doors has been helpful for your overall
chess progression while watching some
chess commentary oh yeah I mean it I
think with chess is that is really hard
to appreciate high level chess because
you cannot as an individual thing like
10 moves ahead as the grandmasters do
but you can try and think at least like
three four head or a moves ahead when
you're watching in high-level clay
because sometimes it's just that amount
it's not always like a lot so you learn
a little bit but you don't really
understand the reasoning unless they're
explaining it to you in industry so I
think it's kind of hard with watching
high-level chess it's better to watch a
high-level chess player coach so what I
think that's actually interesting so the
coaching lessons have been more helpful
well yeah thanks thanks for the feedback
I think that's pretty useful before we
let you guys go he car is there anything
else you'd like dad no not really I
think it's a great match I think both
you
I played played quite well so it was a
good show spoken like the coach of both
players well
forest in chalk Avars thank you so much
for joining us for the interview chat if
you guys want to go check out their
channels as well they are above their
video camps thank you guys and on that
note let's preview the next match thank
you guys thank you so up next we have
little vs. box box this is going to be
the last match of the day takara what
chances would you give Ludwig in this
match so this is this is probably out of
all the matchups that I saw in the first
round the most dangerous for the for the
top rated seed out of all four groups
I think Ludwig based on the little bit
of training that I did with him combined
with the fact that Washington play games
and understanding certain basic shock
mating patterns on it this will be the
most dangerous game for a number one
seed in one of the four groups so I
think what works chances are quite high
especially since he has the white pieces
I'm gonna say Ludwick chances are
probably somewhere around I'm gonna give
him here looking at the engine on the
top of your ceiling dense he carves yeah
I'm gonna give him like a 25 to 30%
chance since he has the white pieces
alright and that's pretty high because
you were saying something like 2084
choco bars right yeah I mean I I think
actually my odds on her a little bit too
I should've been more like ninety ten
instead of eighty twenty but certainly
when it comes to this matchup this is
one of the ones that I'm most looking
forward to and I'm I'm also really
curious to see how Ludwig does because
he's been very impressive from the
little bit that I've seen